The empire may have fallen,
but my ambitions never wavered.
I am grand Admiral Thrawn,
and my return is inevitable.
to do what's right,
regardless of our personal feelings.
by the end of the Clone Wars.
I walked away from him and the Jedi.
I could use the help.
Once a rebel.
Always a rebel.
In this war,
you'll face more than just droids
as your master
is my responsibility to prepare you.
I won't always be there
to look out for you.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Ahsoka Episode 6 is coming.
There are a couple of big Easter eggs in
the trailer, a couple of big plot points
They still need to pay off
before the end of the season.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
we're doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything
We're still doing a giveaway
for the Disney Plus memberships to name
a new winner during this video.
I'm doing that
during all the episode videos.
I'm also going to be doing Loki season
two episodes.
That's going to overlap with the Ahsoka
finale in a couple of weeks.
So we'll roll right into that.
They're a couple brand new trailers
for all that other stuff too.
But since that's Marvel stuff,
I'll just leave that in my Marvel videos.
careful for spoilers from episode five
if you haven't seen it yet.
But at the end of the episode, Ahsoka
came back to the world of the living,
came back to consciousness, so to speak.
got a big called action lesson from Anakin
Skywalker in the world between worlds.
I think that was also meant
to be a bit of a force vision too,
because of the way
Anakin was manipulating it
in in the world between worlds.
Strictly speaking, you're literally
traveling through time and space.
this is probably Dave
Filoni is way to have his cake
and eat it too,
so that he could get around the time
travel paradox
problem of Anna and Skywalker
learning too much about his future
before he became Darth Vader
that's why I said,
I think this version of Anakin
is a little bit closer
to being like a Mortis God,
because they kind of tease that during
the Mortis episodes of the Clone Wars
that he was the chosen
one meant to bring balance to the force.
But that idea went much bigger,
much more beyond just getting
rid of the emperor and bringing balance
to the force during return of the Jedi.
like and again,
is serving a more cosmic role
than he was before,
than a traditional force ghost
would like Yoda's Force Ghost or Obi-Wan
Kenobi is force ghost in present day,
the funny thing about that time
travel paradox too,
is that they actually addressed it
during the Mortis episode
were the son actually showed and again,
his future becoming Darth Vader,
it kind of drove him mad briefly
and he turned evil
and wanted to do all these crazy
things in the galaxy to try and prevent it
and make things worse.
Theoretically.
So the father
basically
had to erase his knowledge of the future.
so just to be clear,
the version of Anakin
that Ahsoka was talking to in the World
Between Worlds is sort of like the dead
version.
In present day.
It is more cosmic force,
ghost type of mortis, God role.
He didn't have the blue outline
of traditional force ghost.
But I do think
before the end of the series
we'll see
a traditional force goes in again
cameos like a more traditional type of
cameo scene, kind of like the quite Gone
Jin cameo scene at the end of the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series.
you could do like five more videos
explaining what Anakin is doing right
now, the way he exists in a more cosmic
God type of role in the force.
but I do think right now he is providing
balance to the universe, the force itself,
the way they said he was prophesied
to do during the Mortis episodes.
That's also why they wanted to trap him
on mortis.
Like, you need to stay here.
You need to bring balance to my family.
Then Ahsoka goes full Gandalf from Lord
of the Rings, Gandalf the White Ahsoka.
The white came back to life
with new knowledge in a serious case.
It was that you just wasn't afraid of
getting people killed anymore,
especially those close to her.
Like Sabine, Ezra, the rest of the crew,
the ghosts.
In order to fight Grand Admiral Thrawn,
She couldn't just take a knee
because she was too afraid
to get people killed.
that was white
and again, took her to all those past
visions of the Clone Wars battles
that they travel to.
she and Hu Yang rode inside the lead
pergolas belly to the other galaxy
to get Sabine and Ezra try to stop Morgan,
Elspeth the Dark Jedi from using the
AI have signed a big hyperspace ring from
bringing Thrawn back to the main galaxy
with his seventh Fleet, or what remains
of his seventh Fleet of Star Destroyers.
being gone for about ten years.
That other galaxy. We'll see.
We learn about other ships, other cultures
in that other galaxy.
I know a lot of people too
are like, Well, it's a spiral galaxy
that looks kind of like the Milky Way.
Maybe that's meant to be our galaxy.
They also keep making the jokes, too.
The Star Wars Introduction.
Because the Star Wars
stories are told as
if they are happening a long time ago
in a galaxy far, far away.
in every time they talk about this with
the galaxy, they say it's far, far away.
but just from the trailer footage of stuff
that we haven't seen yet,
it just seems that they're hyping up
the return of Grand Admiral Thrawn
in most of the rest of the episodes,
like episodes six, seven
and eight will mostly be focused on
what's going on in that other galaxy.
there's the
all the plot that's happening with Hera
in the New Republic in the main galaxy,
but that feels like it's
completely secondary,
like a completely different story
from what's going on with Ahsoka,
trying to find great Admiral
Thrawn, Ezra in Sabine.
that's why I said after episode five,
it felt like Episode five was kind of
like the real beginning of the series,
like when the plot actually begins.
there.
A couple of videos
I did before the season came out
where I was actually talking about this
in relation to The Lord of the Rings,
because we're talking about Ahsoka
being kind of like
the Gandalf of the Star Wars universe.
think of a serious season
one is like the Fellowship of the Ring
with the way they did, the progression
of all the characters.
The first half of the season of Ahsoka
is everything in The Lord of the Rings
Fellowship of the Ring
before the Fellowship actually forms.
then halfway through the season,
the fellowship forms
in the actual real plot begins,
like taking the ring to Mount Doom.
Only this time it's a soldier
going to the other galaxy, defying Grand
Admiral Thrawn, Ezra and Sabine. Now
to their version of the One ring of Power
is the literal giant hyperspace ring.
destroy the ring of power.
Throw it in the fires of Mount Doom.
Let me know what you think.
On Ahsoka represents
Mount Doom in this equation
Maybe at some point during episodes six,
seven and eight, they'll briefly jump back
to what's happening with Harry's group
in the main galaxy.
But for the most part,
I think they're going to just focus on
what's happening with Thorne's group
in the other galaxy in Ahsoka,
when she gets there.
the whole idea with the space wells,
the pergola too, is that when she jokes
about not knowing whether or not
the space wells can actually find
where Morgan Elsbeth in the hyperspace
ring, Wentworth, Thrawn and Ezra are,
there's a very wide margin for error.
Like they could wind
up in the blackness of space,
there's a giant void between galaxies
which would basically render them
completely helpless.
I think the idea is that the purge will
just have the natural ability,
like sort of like a natural hyperspace
sonar where they can detect where things
travel in hyperspace so they can follow
the giant hyperspace rings
trail through hyperspace, there.
He showed us what live action Ezra Bridger
looks like, but he recorded this message
that's being kept
watching about ten years ago
from where they are now in present day.
The actors the same like the same actors
playing the character in present day.
But they might've just made him
look a little bit younger
when they did the hollow recording scene.
basically he's
meant to be about the same age as Sabine
and she's in her late
twenties in present day.
the only of the things that we know
is that he left his light saber with her.
That's what who Jane was talking to her
about in the early episodes.
She's already modified it to her own spec,
even though she's not very good
with it yet.
since he's been stuck
in that other galaxy, he would have either
constructed a new lightsaber for himself
or he just gone without one.
the other big question too,
because this is like a huge other galaxy
that we haven't explored yet
is whether or not Ezra took off
when they arrived in that other galaxy
or if he stayed with Thrawn seventh Fleet
just to survive,
or if he did what Ahsoka just did in asked
the space Wells to do him another solid
and just give him a ride somewhere else.
Because he totally could have just pulled
what Ahsoka just did in right inside
one of their stomachs to the other galaxy,
back to the main galaxy.
like he didn't have to be trapped
in that other galaxy,
but maybe he just
didn't have access to the Pergolas.
Maybe they didn't come anywhere near
where he was the other thing too.
There might be a big twist
in that other galaxy.
There might be something really important
or really powerful
there as well that made him
want to stay in the other galaxy.
But we know
they're doing the Thrawn movie.
Heir to the Empire, loosely based on
the plot of the original Thrawn trilogy.
So that means that he has to make it back
to the regular galaxy in the finale
with his fleet.
to get into the whole night.
Sisters of it all.
The big rumor right now
is that Thrawn is creating an army
for himself with Morgan Elspeth help.
And they're going to be
a bunch of knights,
sister zombies like Barack was like
Merak was meant
to be kind of a teaser
foreshadowing for casual audience.
What Theron's grand plan
is conquering the galaxy
so that when a bunch of Knights sister
zombie show up, people
who don't really know Star Wars understand
kind of how they work.
They did a lot of the Knights
sister zombies during the Star Wars.
Jedi games like Jedi, Fallen
Order, Jedi Survivor.
They also did them during the Clone Wars
episodes.
So if you watched any of those, you have
a pretty good idea what's going on.
ID that winds up being true,
I think that's meant to be his version
of creating a massive fighting force
that he has total control
over with Morgan Elsbeth help
because technically the night sister
would be the one creating them like Moff
Gideon wanted to do with his clone.
Army of force sensitive clones
bring the extra hard core
Mandalorian Beskar armor,
making them nearly invincible, basically
people creating their invincible,
fighting forces in different ways.
Nice sister.
Zombies aren't invincible, but like
Merauke, they're already dead, basically.
So they feel no pain.
They have no limits.
Like normal soldiers or normal clones,
because we did just have a bunch
of live action Clone Wars flashbacks.
The funny thing too,
is that
during the final days of the Empire,
before the events of A New Hope,
the Emperor Grand Moff Tarkin,
top military brass were considering
going back to using the traditional
clone troopers again
instead of regular humanoid troopers.
Most of them had died
in battle or natural causes.
But for the events
of the original trilogy,
There are a few traditional clones
that live to very old age.
Like Rex, for example,
he's still alive in present day tomorrow.
Morrison had a brief cameo
during the episode,
but it was a flashback version of Rex.
But most of them just died out
naturally in battle or of old age.
And the Emperor just eventually replace
them with regular human stormtroopers.
the problem that they ran into,
the problem
the emperor ran into is that
humans have free will end,
even though they condition them
in really hardcore
ways, they're much harder to control
on a massive scale than the clones
were Just remember how Order 66 went down.
what ended up happening,
though, is that the rebellion
formed in the Galactic Civil War happened
during the original trilogy,
so the Empire never got the chance
to bring the clone Troopers back,
so to speak.
but then you have the Imperial Remnant.
A lot of those survivors, like the Shadow
Council, whose plans for stuff
like that evolve into bigger things
like Moff Gideon is playing for force
sensitive Clone Troopers, fort,
The Thrawn rumor is true using Knights,
Sisters, Powers of Resurrection
to create a zombie army basically.
The funny thing about Rock two
like we tell the Merak jokes now
the director of episode four where he was
killed, revealing him as a knights
or zombie with that Sprayberry in smoke
wasn't something that the director
actually knew about.
Peter Ramsey, who directed
the episode, was one of the directors
on Spider-Man into the Spider-Verse
amazing movie, one of the best Spider-Man
movies of all time.
He said that Dave Filoni wouldn't
tell him what was going on
with Mark during the episode,
only that they wanted him
to kill Merauke
and have something spray out of his chest.
Peter Ramsey said when they were filming
the scene, they just assumed
it was supposed to be blood spraying out
when he was killed by a soldier.
But because it's meant to be PG 13,
it couldn't be too hardcore.
So they didn't make it
look like red blood.
but it also didn't look green either.
They actually made it
look green in post-production.
So Peter Ramsey had no idea
what was going on with Mark,
with the green smoke coming out of him,
like, Oh, that's a brand new thing.
what might have been going
on, though, is that
Dave Filoni wouldn't reveal
all the secrets about Merauke to the crew
that were filming that
part of the episode with the nicest zombie
because it was part of this larger plot
that Thrawn has to create
an army of these types of beings.
Either way, we should see pretty soon
what's going on
with Thrawn in that of the galaxy and
what kind of force he's going to assemble
going to need a ton of able
bodied troops really fast.
And he did
not have that many of them with him
when he was taken to the other galaxy.
so he has to magic up an army of people
pretty quickly.
In nicest zombies
would be a really easy way to do that
Right now,
my expectation is that they'll just deal
with this soldier
getting into the other galaxy
and finding everyone,
and they'll hold off
on some of the big reveal.
It's like the very end of the episode.
They might see a little bit
what's going on with Ezra a little bit,
what's going on with Ryan,
Morgan, Elsbeth, The Dark Jedi and Sabine.
But for the most part, they're going
to hold the real big reveals, too,
like Episode seven in Episode eight,
let me know in the comments.
Why do you think that Ezra didn't
already use the space wheels to travel
back to the normal galaxy?
Like why you write in their stomachs
and come back on his own already
My full episode six video will post
next week after they release it.
They also just released a bunch
of big trailers for like Loki season two.
All coming in to
that should be later today.
So I'll do videos for that stuff. Next,
Be sure to enable alerts on my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
Congratulations, Toxie Nine seven
five four
You're the giveaway winner for my last
big Star Wars giveaway.
Please email me
on the about page of my channel on desktop
so I can get your contact details.
Click here for my
Ahsoka episode 5 video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!